oh she's doing okay she's at home she's  in bed right now she's watching  everything on television she sees me  but she is hanging in you know we used  to go to  sue the red carpet you know all the time  you know she enjoyed to go with me to do  it but unfortunately she had the  accident she can't do it anymore but  she's watching it she's happy i checked  out she said yeah you look okay you can  go like that and that's it so so she's  with the cheese part of hollywood i  represented  who's the most important person in her  career  the most important person and here  hopefully me  hopefully  doing lots of scandals because hollywood  is a big scandal factory that's what it  is hollywood without scandal wouldn't be  hollywood  you